benefit 2.0 is packing on the pda in the
big apple jennifer lopez and ben affleck
were photographed locking lips and
getting romantic with one another while
walking the streets of new york city on
sunday morning and it just turned out to
be something really magical jayla looked
chic as she stayed warm in a green and
blue full-length tartan coat over a
similarly colored wrapped dress
meanwhile ben sported a gray wool blazer
over a black polo and dark jeans the
cute couple embraced kissed laughed and
talked while maintaining their hug and
all without worrying about being spotted
by anyone passing by i find myself
incredibly blessed the outing came one
day after ben showed a support for
jennifer at her performance at the
global citizen live event on saturday
the concert marked the singer's first
performance since the two confirmed
their relationship what am i doing with
my life
now this isn't the first time bennefer
has proven that they're each other's
biggest fans since recoupling earlier
this month ben got this sweet shout out
from jen a clip from their time at the
venice film festival promoting his
latest movie the last duel in the post
jlo shared she had such a beautiful time
in venice adding quote i'm so excited
for you guys to see this movie it's the
first script matt and ben have written
together since goodwill hunting and it's
amazing the premiere was their red
carpet re-debut as a couple honestly i
get a joy in creating and doing things
like that expect a lot more benefit
sightings in the coming months a source
told et earlier this month that they're
gearing up for the holidays together and
could not be more in love it is like
they never broke up but everything is
way better this time they are all over
each other and their friends joke around
about it with them i'm ready i'm excited
about it our source adds they plan on
spending the holidays together and also
taking some solo trips they want to be
together all of the time so their next
big things are thanksgiving and
christmas there's a lot to coordinate so
they are figuring it out
[Music]
you